[Music]
and the pressure is crazy Saints is in
so much trouble right now not looking
good but hall sorry it ended he's in
rage I don't know what to say he can't
do much and Jane that ACR is our evil
2017 champion appropriately in a very
robotic fashion yes he is a machine
JDC are manages to pull through and win
championship for Tekken 7 very very nice
work incredible performance he is like a
machine and I told you man I'm not gonna
cry you're not gonna cry we don't cry
here with one of these guys probably
will okay this guy deserves it I was
talking up early on when he did get
sponsored by a fox he was giving up you
know I mean he's getting older in Korea
madisyn sizes choice all right crying
I'm gonna
[Music]
okay no wall
or this is getting bad Chanel needs to
make some room right now he has way too
much life oh wow acquainted I'm not over
is your 2016 king of our fans what
hippies over dick I cannot believe I
just compensated a thing for a job do
smoke I've been watching the goods for
tension so good
[Music]
yeah we got a translation through here
I'm backseat a goddess
[Music]
a sick jacket
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh nice break me running - oh my god
this is so intense right now back for
good we have a champion and Nobby is
Rapinoe IRS Tournament 2015 grand
champion protective goggles if you're
gonna be here in the audience
nice work is gonna cry I love that
emotional
you
again thank you everybody for tuning in
you know anywhere there's more yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
the ball
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so much damage
[Music]
big dorsal puss
Second World Tour Finals champion
[Applause]
this man has come a long way this man
has come a long way
raise that bad boy up there you go
that's your tech the World Tour champion
that's your second World Tour champion
[Music]